I have to say something about you
Tell me.
before you go into me.
I just admire you so,
and I'm so proud of you.
I feel like proud, like a mama.
So, good on you.
(audience applauding)
I think this is incredible.
I think it's incredible.
Really happy for you.
And you have been someone
that's like been one of my favorite actresses.
I know, you know, "Better Things"
has really come to that forefront
'cause it's current and it's been
the last several years of your life
and you've done things with it
that like wasn't happening on shows.
I mean, you look at the way that scene is shot.
Like that is not your typical television show.
That is art.
There is movement.
There's really interesting edits.
There's musicality to it, literally and metaphorically.
And you're looking at people,
so the scene is with two people
that you're never gonna see again,
but it's really about the interactions,
that my character's name is Sam
and what other people bring into your life.
And you know, it's really about the village.
And I'm a single mom.
I have three daughters and there was a certain point
that I finally went, "Okay so, after I have three,
it's just a whirlwind.
Now it's time to bring your friends in."
And then you feel what the village is like.
And it's something that we do in my show
where you push the boundaries and with the girls and Sam,
they need to know that they could do the worst thing
and that she's still gonna be there.
Yes.
But there's a point where you get to an age,
where the kids grow up, and there's a level of respect.
And so, there's just these many kind of gradations
of family and growth.
And this has been five seasons
and I started the show seven years ago.
All of my kids were living at home then-
I know. (clapping)
And if this show is...
No it's fun.
This show is so accoladed.
Why, 'cause you are the mother of three daughters.
Yup.
How did you look at your life
through a lens of, "I could tell the story of this."
Yeah, it was...
I think it was when my mother was driving me crazy,
which was always...
And she'd just be
(Drew laughing)
telling stories or whatever.
And, you know, I found myself like...
I finally looked at my mother one day
and I just went, "Oh, she's funny."
"This is funny."
And so if you change the perspective
of how you receive the information
and I have this saying which is,
"Bad for my life, good for my show."
So it's...
Oh my God, that is a whoa.
Yes.
I just appreciate how you can bring
heart and humor and keep it real
for all of us moms out there
who are so hard on ourselves already
as if we needed more pressure.
Yep.
So thank you
Thank you.
for doing that.
That's very sweet.
(audience applauding)
I really appreciate that.
It's so awesome.
Thank you.
I want nothing more in this world
than to keep it real, but keep aspirations high.
We all gotta aspire.
Yeah.
Pamela, will you play, as a finisher,
my favorite game with me, The Final Five?
Oh yes.
Okay, great.
A game?
I get a Final Five, everybody.
(audience applauding)
(drum roll)
All right, I talk with Rosie Perez about hickeys.
Hickeys, yay or nay?
Oh.
(audience laughing)
Yes.
Very much so.
Yay, I love hickeys too.
(audience applauding)
I want one.
Okay, favorite curse word?
Oh man.
It's like we're fully in "Actors Studio" right now.
We're allowed to s...
and James Lipton
is here and yeah.
How about (bleep).
I love it.
(audience applauding)
(both laughing)
Your favorite late night snack?
You're at the fridge and you're going for it.
Persian cucumbers with lemon and sea salt flakes.
That's not the naughtiest I've ever heard
but it's delicious.
Sliced.
Okay, your favorite chore?
Cooking.
The last Google search you did?
(Pamela exhales)
"The Drew Barrymore Show".
Really, awesome.
I love that.
(audience applauding)
Oh Pamela.
How does it feel?
Tonight is the night you close out
this profound chapter in your life
and for all of those viewers
who have loved and been loyal to the show,
how does it feel?
I feel so grateful and I'm really, really happy.
I have this beautiful five seasons
of a story of a family and their friends
and the village and it's magical.
It's just, I feel I'm floating on air.
Well, thank you for putting it out into the world.
Thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
The series finale of "Better Things"
airs tonight on FX and is streaming on Hulu.
(upbeat music)